und der Bundesverteidigungsminister ist
uns zugeschaltet guten Abend Herr
Pistorius guten Abend Frau slomker sind
jetzt ziemlich genau ein Jahr im Amt und
haben sich in der Zeit ja ein Namen
damit gemacht Dinge auszusprechen die
andere nicht mal denken wollen jetzt
haben sie z.B davor gewarnt dass sich
die natooländer auf einen russischen
Angriff auf auf auch auf ihr Territorium
einrichten müssen an was für Szenarien
denken sie denn da es geht weniger darum
sich konkret auf einen Angriff
vorzubereiten oder einzurichten aber
damit rechnen muss man und wenn man mit
etwas rechnen muss ich auf eine Gefahr
einstellen muss von der man nicht weiß
ob und wann sie eintritt dann heißt das
man muss ich dafür wappnen und das tun
wir gerade gemeinsam mit den Alliierten
in der NATO und das ist auch notwendig
also man kann sich ja durchaus konkrete
Szenarien vorstellen z.B im Baltikum da
wird dann einen Aufstand der russischen
Minderheit inszeniert dann greift
baltisches Militär ein dann heißt es aus
russischer Seite müssen unsere Leute
schützen und dann rollen eventuell
Panzer und fliegen Kampfhubschrauber das
wäre dann eigentlich genau der Moment wo
dann auch die deutsche litaauenbrigade
zum Einsatz käme oder na ja das ist
genau der Punkt deswegen stellen wir die
ja auf um gleich vor Ort präsent zu sein
mit dieser Brigade und die wird 27
einsatzbereit sein aber so lange braucht
es um die Brigade aufzustellen deswegen
sagen wir ja immer die Militärexperten
gehen von einem Zeitraum von mehreren
Jahren aus die es braucht bis Russland
überhaupt wieder in der Lage wäre das
ist eine Schätzung genau wissen tut das
niemand und diese Zeit müssen wir die
nächsten dre bis 5 Jahre müssen wir
intensiv nutzen um uns zu wappnen und
sagt der Inspekteur des heres jetzt
schon wir haben eigentlich gar nicht
genug Leute und auch nicht genug
Material um diese Brigade zu bestücken
die kann ja auch nicht 2027 plötzlich
aufploppen das muss er jetzt eigentlich
losgehen aber dafür ist die Bundeswehr
noch gar nicht ausgerüstet nee das ist
nicht ganz richtig wir beschaffen ja
gerade in großem Stil und mit hoher
Geschwindigkeit wir haben alleine im
Jahr
2023 mehr 25 Millionen Euro Vorlagen in
den Haushaltsausschuss eingebracht als
jemals zuvor über 50 und im nächsten
Jahr werden wir vielleicht sogar
dreistellig werden das heißt wir haben
das Tempo bei der Beschaffung deutlich
erhöht und gleichzeitig gehört eben dann
auch dazu sich einzugestehen wir können
schneller bestellen aber der zweite
Schritt ist die Industrie muss schneller
produzieren und darüber sind wir im
Gespräch Industrie sagt aber dass sie
auch viele Aufträge bislang nicht
bekommen hat ja das ist mir neu also in
allen relevanten Bereichen das gilt für
Munition das gilt für gepanzerte
Fahrzeuge und vieles andere mehr
Artillerie und Patriot Systeme sind die
auf der die Aufträge raus oder in
unmittelbarer Vorbereitung wir geben
richtig Gas W sich das jetzt mal aber
trotzdem mal konkret in Litauen
angeschaut und die Brigade müsste jetzt
schon loslegen dann hätte die analoge
Funkgeräte mit denen sie sich mit den
anderen Europäern gar nicht verständigen
kann und die Panzer die dann da rollen
würden könnten zicht tolle Leopard 2
sein aber es gäbe keine Heeres
Flugabwehr die diese Panzer schützen
würde und das haben wir jetzt der
Ukraine gesehen was das dann bedeutet
wenn man nicht genügend Luftabwehr hat
Flugabwehr hat jetzt rechenen sich
haushaltstechnisch begründete
Entscheidung von vor einigen Jahren als
man die heresflugabwehr ersatzlos
abgeschafft hat hat das müssen wir jetzt
wieder aufbauen mit völlig neuem Gerät
aber auch da sind wir dabei aber klar
muss auch sein der Krieg gegen die
Ukraine dieser furchtbare Krieg geht ins
dritte Jahr das heißt vor zwei Jahren
hat er begonnen
und in dieser Zeit haben wir viel
geschafft aber wir können nicht in zwei
Jahren die kertwende ein zu ein
vollziehen und aufholen auf den Stand
den wir eigentlich bräuchten in einer
Zeit die einfach zu kurz dafür war aber
dass wir jetzt im Ende des zweiten
Kriegsjahres sind und die Europäer nicht
in der Lage sind der Ukraine genügend
Munition Artilleriemunition zu
beschaffen also dass das versprochene
Ziel nicht mal erreicht wird das spricht
jetzt eigentlich nicht dafür dass man
sehr viel begriffen hat vor zwei Jahren
und sehr viel unternommen hat na ja der
diese munitionsinitiative ist etwa ein
knappes Jahr alt ich habe damals davor
gewarnt dass das eine hohe Erwartung ist
die man damit weckt und sehr wohl im
Auge behalten muss ob denn die
Rüstungsindustrie dazu überhaupt so
schnell in der Lage sein wird und es
zeigt sich dass sie es nicht war nicht
sein konnte weil die Kapazitäten die
Produktionskapazitäten einfach noch
nicht da sind sie w auf aber auch das
geht jetzt nicht das geht nicht von
jetzt auf gleich das sind alles die
Baustellen auf denen wir mit Hochdruck
arbeiten mit der Industrie zusammen wir
sind sehr kooperativ mit denen unterwegs
die wissen worauf es ankommt aber dazu
gehört auch dass wir als Bundesregierung
dass ich als Verteidigungsminister die
Mittel habe um langfristige Bestellung
aufzugeben die dann wiederum die
Planungssicherheit auch für die
Industrie bedeuten ja sie wollten z.B 10
Milliarden mehr im regulären werita
bekommen haben sie rund 1,8 ja das ist
so so ist das in der Politik wenn es um
Haushalt geht gleichzeitig haben wir
aber das Sondervermögen und mit diesem
sonder mit Hilfe dieses Sondervermögens
kommen wir in diesem Jahr äh auf über 3
Milliarden Euro insgesamt Ausgaben für
Rüstung und das ist der höchste Betrag
den es jemals gab und er wird weiter
steigen müssen das wissen alle 2027 ist
dieser Topf alle ja auch das ist keine
neue Erkenntnis das ist völlig richtig
und alle wissen dass ab 27 der et dann
der eigentliche et des
Verteidigungsministeriums aufwachsen
muss darüber werden sich jetzt die
Haushaltsexperten in diesem und im
kommenden Jahr Gedanken machen weil
natürlich sichergestellt sein muss dass
wir auch über die jahresgrenzen der
jeweiligen Haushalte hinaus planen und
beschaffen können weil wir noch lange
nicht am Ende dessen sind was wir
brauchen jetzt ist es so die Zuschauer
die uns jetzt zuhören wie wir über
Granaten und taubitzen und und und
Heeres Flugabwehr und ähnliches reden
von denen wird ein Teil mit dem Kopf
nicken und sagen ja ja ja das muss für
alles jetzt viel schneller gehen aber es
wird auch ein großer Teil das als Graus
empfinden und das auch für falsch halten
und für etwas was eher die Sache noch
viel gefährlicher macht wenn jetzt
massiv aufgerüstet wird wie wollen Sie
diesen Teile der Bevölkerung da
mitnehmen zunächstm würde ich sagen ich
habe für jeden Verständnis der sich
dabei unwohl fühlt dass mehr Waffen
beschäft beschafft werden das verstehe
ich menschlich und emotional sehr wohl
aber die Erfahrung aus der Geschichte
des Kalten Krieges und die Situation die
wir jetzt haben mit diesem putin ist
viel unberechenbarer lehrt eben auch
dass Abschreckung das einzig wirksame
Mittel ist um sich gegen einen möglichen
Aggressor von vorne rein äh zu
positionieren sozusagen Greif uns nicht
an wir werden in der Lage sein und
willend sein und zu verteidigen wenn man
das aber will muss man auch die Mittel
dafür haben und das heißt man muss
glaubhaft abschrecken um zu verhindern
dass es überhaupt zu einem
kriegsausbrich Ausbruch kommt diese
Logik wird aber auch von Teilen ihrer
eigenen Partei nicht geteilt also Herr
Mützen nicht bekommt schon die Krise
wenn sie von kriegstüchtigkeit sprechen
also ich glaube er steht voll hinter den
Ausgaben die wir tätigen müssen dass
sich einige an dem Wort kriegstüchtig
stören verstehe ich aber im Grunde
genommen ich kann es wiederholen
bedeutet Tüchtigkeit laut Deutschem
Duden nicht mehr als eine besondere Form
der Tauglichkeit es geht also darum dass
wir uns in die Lage versetzen müssen
einen Krieg zu führen der uns
aufgezwungen wird keinen den wir
beginnen das versteht sich von selbst
aber wenn wir angegriffen werden müssen
wir Krieg führen können
und das ist das entscheiden und darauf
müssen wir uns vorbereiten also die
Formel lautet Krieg führen zu können um
keinen Krieg führen zu müssen her
Pistorius danke für das Gespräch sehr
gerne Frau slamker
Fela